hi everyone my name is saya venom with
the IBM cloud team today we want to talk
about kubernetes deployments deploying
your applications kubernetes doesn't
have to be difficult but first let's
introduce what a pod is a pod is a
smallest logical unit that you can
deploy into a kubernetes cluster however
to really harness the power of
kubernetes you need to deploy those pods
using a kubernetes deployment resource
kubernetes resources are managed using
gamal and here we've got some mammal
that defines how to deploy a sample
application into kubernetes taking a
look at the yamo starting at the top we
can see things like the kind of resource
it is so we see that it's a deployment
in addition we define some metadata and
the name for this artifact going a
little bit lower we can see that we
define the number of replicas that we
want this kubernetes deployment to
manage as well as a match selector which
connects the pods to this deployment
resource finally at the bottom we see
the template this is the most important
part of a kubernetes deployment and
defines the pod
that it will be deploying and here we
can see things like the name of the
image as well as things like the port
that it will listen on and various
configuration like environment variables
we'll take this Djamel and using cube
CTL as CLI tool we'll deploy that yamo
into a kubernetes cluster at which point
kubernetes will create a deployment
resource which in turn creates a replica
set a replica set is simply there to
manage identical copies of a pod and to
make sure that they're running and
healthy next let's talk about updating
that deployment so we'll go back to the
yeah mol and let's say that we want to
up the number of replicas from two to
three and we'll also change the image
maybe we'll go from v1 of the
application to v2 after we make the
changes to the Hamel file we'll deploy
it using coop CTL at which point the
kubernetes recognizes the change to that
deployment and creates a new replica set
with that new image and the number of
replicas kubernetes will then do a
rolling update to make sure no downtime
is happening while those pods are being
updated to the new version of that image
finally what about the leading and
deployment
with kubernetes using the same Yammer
that you use to actually create that
resource you can also delete those same
resources by using another cube CTL
command you can pass that deployment
yellow in and delete those resources
from kubernetes life is good when all of
your applications are working but let's
talk about some key debugging techniques
to figure out when things go wrong the
first one I like to use is cube CTL logs
you can pass in the ID of a pod that was
created by that deployment and find logs
from the containers running within it in
fact you can even use the - - previous
flag to find logs from a previously
crashed container which is generally the
case if you're trying to debug something
wrong with your containers next I like
to use the cube CTL described command
along with the pod to find any events
that have been thrown to help you figure
out what went wrong the cube see tail
described command has a lot of output
but at the bottom by taking a look at
these events you can figure out exactly
what happened
for example maybe the wrong port was
defined or the wrong image has been
pulled if neither of those techniques
work for you you can also SSH directly
into a pod in kubernetes and run things
like PS to make sure that the right
processes are running you can also check
out the file system to identify any logs
that might be coming out from the
processes running within that pod I
think those are three major ways that
can help you debug any issue with their
kubernetes deployments thanks for
joining me today this was a quick
overview of kubernetes deployments if
you have any questions or feedback feel
free to drop a comment below and stay
tuned to subscribe for more videos like
this in the future